one of the beautiful things about this
show is really meeting and connecting
with amazing people and creating spaces
for them
to share their stories and experiences
and one way we've been able to do that
is by teaming up with
lovey aji jones this is our fourth
segment together and she is one of the
co-creators of the share the mic
campaign in fact go ahead and take a
look
mission to share the mic now is to
amplify the voices of black women giving
them a platform
and igniting change through sisterhood
and this is why i'm really excited about
today's
share the mic now guest because it's
beauty week it's only fair that i bring
on an amazing beauty boss
her name is melissa r butler and she's
ceo and founder
of the lip bar a cruelty free beauty
brand that is on a mission to change the
way we think about beauty
she's also a fellow midwestern girl so
you know i have a soft spot for
and honestly on this show i've been on
about four times so far
i've probably had on the lip bar three
out of those four times because
their reds are the perfect red for
anybody y'all meet melissa all weather
hi lovey how are you
hey drew oh it's so nice to see you you
know i
put on the lip bar lip liner when we
were giving the history of the red lip
it is the most
incredible formula listen it's so good
it is it just makes you feel like you
are instantly
on point no it's so true
well lovey without further ado i would
love
to meet melissa the amazing woman that
you have brought on you're
absolutely right as our fourth time
together and i
can't wait to do many more um hello
melissa
hey drew hey lovey good morning hey
melissa
oh my goodness melissa your lips
i'm sorry they're like day glow they are
so beautiful
is that lip bar of course so this is
my favorite color this one is boy
trouble oh
and it's like a liquid matte so it won't
come off
you know that's the kind of boy trouble
i'm looking for
lovey you have a question for melissa
why don't you kick us off
so melissa i'm wearing boss lady which
you already know is my favorite
i know how do you come up with these
titles
boss lady brick house boy trouble how do
you come up with titles for the lips
so the names like i personally name
every single product and i get so much
joy out of it
the whole goal is just to describe our
customers and to remind people that
that women are not a monolith right so
we can be
a boss lady we can be boy trouble we can
be first lady we can be madam president
yeah
yes and so that's really how i think
about naming
the product we've been talking a lot
on this show about how i want to create
a mood board because women are not just
one thing we are interested in beauty we
are interested
in family we are interested in business
you know i love
art and design and so many things but i
love
business and i'm really interested in
how you grow
something and like being productive and
i'm just so many things and
it's so amazing to talk to you guys
because melissa your
your path to this company wasn't
traditional
tell us how you started no
most people who have makeup companies
they were either makeup artists or they
just have like this deep passion for
makeup
for me i've never been a makeup girl i
actually
worked on wall street and i started the
company making lipstick in my kitchen
again not because i was so in love with
makeup but really because i was
frustrated with the beauty industry it's
lack of diversity
the excessive amounts of chemicals and
this idea that women were supposed to
fit in this beauty box and i was like no
instead of complaining about it i'm
gonna change it i mean
i also think that your experience in
finance is such an
asset because it is one thing to be a
creative
but if you don't have a business prowess
you're not going to make it and if
you're all business
and don't have any creative it's not
going to work either you really need
both lovey how did you discover
melissa and like meet each other and
find each other
you know what's funny it is a full
circle moment because i was on kelana
bartholo brown's
instagram one day this was years ago and
kelana's
been on the show a couple of times and
she had on this amazing red lip and i
said
i need you to let me know this color
right now and she was like oh it's the
lip bar boss lady and i was like i'm
ordering it
right now and that's how i discovered
lip bar and now i have like
seven of their lip colors any reds that
i'm wearing whether plums or like
fire it's probably the lip bar i love
that and i
love kalana and she has mad style and
how i met kalana was she was a big
beauty editor and i used to bring her
flower beauty and meet her at desk sides
now
both of you are i'm just looking at you
and i'm sorry i never hold back you're
both so stunning
you're both so beautiful and
i would love to ask you if you uh go
into lit bar
and go on the webpage what is one
product that you would say
start with oh
so i mean i think you start with a lip
the lip is the thing that changes your
entire face
but as of late my jam has been concealer
it's what makes me look a little bit
more alive on my zoom calls
absolutely and you have an amazing full
face palette and a whole
get ready in seven minutes which i think
every woman
can appreciate like give me a stopwatch
because that's kind of how
life is working anyway so i just think
you've
really figured out you know clean beauty
the business side the creative side you
you know you had you were on shark tank
and it like didn't work out but look at
you now and it's like
i love that because i think that's
important for people to hear because
roadblocks can make you feel like it's
never going to happen
and it's like you're crushing it and i
have to say
in the beauty industry that i'm involved
in being a beauty junkie and a beauty
business owner
people really respect lipbar it is a
very loved respected loyalty to a
company
you have really done it and i am so
honored to share
my instagram page with you today it's
something lovey and i have done with
everybody and i am just
honored and lovey gosh you really do
have like the knack you always find the
most beautiful
on the inside and out real trail
blazer women and i'm just so honored to
do this show with you lovey really and
truly
thank you guys so much we will be right
back
melissa will be on instagram and
obviously all of this information will
be on our website as well
thank you ladies so much thank you
thank you thank you thank you